no no that's not no no mother
you
Oh what is going on YouTube for those of
you who have not seen this lovely video
Oh God
ha this video is a lovely song about a
cute little white girl and about how
much she loves Chinese food and uh Wow
hmm no no what you thinking you guys
probably want me to talk about how
racist and derogatory the video was but
I'm not here to talk about that in fact
if you put that song on Sesame Street it
would have been a culturally uplifting
song about how white people are that
stupid about Asian culture mmm think
about it it's kind of like if I did a
song about white people and hot dogs and
hamburgers see I like that [ __ ] but you
know singing about it would be stupid as
[ __ ]
I like Burger King it gives me diarrhea
it gives me diarrhea now the person we
should be targeting is not Little Miss
Goldilocks it should be the brother in
the [ __ ] panda suit cause it's
your fantasy now about first class if
you do not recognize him by now let me
refresh your memory
yeah I'd be Rebecca Black so chillin in
the front I'm actually actually driving
Susie he's the brother that produced and
rap on the track
it's Friday Bobby what the am i doing
you sir should have the tip of your dick
tied to the front of an alligator's
mouth that's right this blog is about
you yeah [ __ ] Panda pedo bear look
didn't you do enough with Friday huh you
single-handedly ruined my favorite day
of the week you [ __ ] [ __ ] hmm you
know what you got you got a face that'll
set off the AMBER Alert in two seconds
you perverted Mick chocolate bunny
outfit but what's wrong with you tops
about losing your stripes you made that
sorry ass beat and you know damn well
you wrote those lyrics too
how do you like if I got a little aging
on the restaurant soul food huh I like
collard green apple pie chickens and
some mac and cheese and some mashed
potatoes the [ __ ] was I doing together
this is some color on color Cartman let
me check something my inner sassy black
woman is crying me a river right now
it's okay baby Shh if I see you in
person I'm a bunny eyes out with some
sulfur aid in a hot comb [ __ ] I don't
even like saying people are weird
because I'm a weird person myself but
you are the weirdest man I have never
met ha ha what was with your goddamn
face in the video
you look way too happy to be inside a
panda costume touching little babies
your filthy baby touch her I said it
tell me I'm not the only one who thought
this was weird
the is with the grant allows this little
girl to roll the grass game tickle by
this pedobear huh
that's like 4000 counts of sexual
assault
and look at this [ __ ] you said Panda
Express you panda [ __ ] that ain't
Chinese food if you were gonna use a
Chinese restaurant you should have said
some [ __ ] like now I'm going to eat
Royal dragon gold and Dragons chance one
dragon for some reason had the Chinese
restaurants in the world had the word
dragon in it I don't know so said you
don't even know how to racially
stereotyped aquas een [ __ ] yourself what
you see that part in the video but it
was revealed the dude in the pen suit
was a 40 year old brother you know their
reaction was fake as hell if that [ __ ]
was real like you know both those little
white girls when I ran the [ __ ] away you
know what not I think about it
you look like one of those brothers that
got an asian fetish look here you either
shape the time Derek Fisher you you
better find an antidote for your Saigon
fever because they nobody want to touch
you and let's be real on an ethnic point
after you made this video nobody's gonna
want to claim you on their side you look
like the only black man on earth that's
not allowed to drop the n-word even why
people look at you and be like oh what's
up on here don't you dare
but on a more serious note dude if you
drop another video like this I'm gonna
have to assassinate you and I'm gonna be
real with you I'm gonna do it in the
weirdest way possible imma throw you in
the ocean with six pieces of tuna tied
to the back of your neck with a pack of
starving dolphins yep that's what um
watch them beat the [ __ ] out that back
on your neck with y'all dumb ass face
record that [ __ ] and put it on YouTube
play some Friday as I edit the video
eating Chinese food
ultimate win
somewhere between psychotic an iconic
somewhere between I won it and I got it
somewhere between us so when I'm lifting
I like Burger King